Speaker 1: One of the funniest little
details in this entire saga of people
protesting at the homes of not only Supreme
Court justices, but also Republican senators,
is that Republican Senator Susan Collins from
Maine decided to call the police because there
was chalk writing on the sidewalk outside
of her house. This is like the epitome
of the triggered snowflake. And I. I am sensitive
to others being sensitive about protests at their
homes. And we had a very good conversation on
the show yesterday with Coleman Hughes about it.
But the police over chalk, when you supposedly
are a defender of speech, you know, the the free
the I'm fine having a good faith conversation
about protests at people's houses. I'm glad to
do it. But when you're talking about free speech
absolutists who all of a sudden say chalk isn't
okay, that's a bit of a problem. Businessinsider
reports Susan Collins called the police to report
report, quote, defacement of public property after
someone wrote an abortion rights message in chalk
on a public sidewalk outside of her House.
Republican Senator Susan Collins of Maine,
one of just two nominally pro-choice Republicans
in the Senate, called the police Saturday night
because of an abortion rights message written
in chalk in front of her house in Bangor,
Maine. According to the Bangor Daily News,
officers responded to a call at 920 because
a message appeared on the sidewalk. It read
Susie, please, Mainers want W.H. to vote yes.
Clean up your mess. EPA means the Women's Health
Protection Bill, which would codify abortion
rights afforded by Roe v Wade into federal law.
This is an idea that is an important idea that's
being increasingly discussed. Well, okay, the
Supreme Court can overturn Roe v Wade by legal
precedent. But if we codify abortion rights into
federal law, it overrides and supersedes that.
The message was not overtly threatening, said Wade
Betters, a spokesperson for the police department.
We are grateful that Susan
Collins said to the Daily News.
We are grateful to the Bangor Police officers and
the city public works employees who responded to
the defacement of public property in front of
our home. Guys, I mean, we're not talking about
poster paint here. We're not talking about spray
paint. We're talking about chalk which washes away
when it rains or with a bucket or a hose to call
this defacement. This isn't graffiti. This is what
kids do all the time. They write with chalk on
the sidewalk. And there's this. I don't want to
put all of this on Susan Collins because it's not
it's not uniquely her. That's the hypocrite here.
But it's the big picture of all of this. On the
one hand, Republicans have been so hesitant to say
the president led and incited an insurrection and
there should be no consequences on the one hand.
And then on the other hand, someone wrote with
chalk, call the cops. It. It's it's one of these.
The message here is a message of authoritarianism,
of shutting down public speech and protest,
throwing things in a senator at a
senator. Of course not. Absolutely not.
Going on the property of individuals to protest.
Absolutely not. You know, whatever else?
No. Writing with chalk on the sidewalk. That
seems like a real problem when that now becomes
something that police are called over. You can't
write with chalk on a sidewalk. But then you can
tell the woman to carry a pregnancy to term
or you don't want to hold Trump accountable
for the things that he did. So I think that
this is an outrageous little micro episode
about how the big picture conversation is kind of
missing the forest for the trees. And by the way,
I got a few angry emails after my conversation
yesterday with Coleman Hughes from people saying,
David, how can you be worried about protests
at someone's house when women are being
disenfranchized from even being able to
make decisions about their own bodies,
decisions which can be life and death? There
are two separate situations. I am completely,
overwhelmingly, unequivocally disgusted by what
we believe to be the forthcoming decision on Roe
v Wade. And I also think there's a good faith
discussion to be had about protesting at the
houses of Supreme Court justices that it's okay
to be able to discuss the two things separately.
And a handful of people are so maybe more like a
dozen didn't like that. We were even having the
discussion. And by the way, I also have a problem
with that. I know about this whole we're just
asking questions thing and how it can be used to
cover in ways that aren't particularly productive.
When Tucker says some people say 10,000 people
died from the COVID vaccine, we're just asking
questions on the show. I get the problem.
Problematic nature of just asking questions.
But to say I shouldn't even be having the
conversation about protest strategy and tactics.
No, guys, that that's not that that that's
not any kind of support of robust discussion
that I can agree with. So maybe maybe rethink
that. We will have more on all of these stories
on The David Pakman Show Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show. And if you
want to see me with a big black and white
animal, was it a cow or was it a zebra?
Many people are asking what exactly
was the animal I was pictured with?
Follow me on my personal Instagram at David
Pakman. We'll take a quick break and be right back